E aí
[Música]
é uma bela tarde e
é uma belíssima tarde para todos voces
é um dia cheio de luz e
é um abraço
é um abraço infinito e
o cumprimento dos assim porque prefiro
fazê-lo sem o artifício do costumo Boa
tarde
é porque buscar o bem mesmo sem vos
conhecer
é porque se alguém nos colocou frente a
frente é porque temos algo partilhar
eu também não vou agradecer por ter
vindo e
e Há momentos em que as pessoas se
juntam
é porque assim tem que ser
é porque a vida em caixa
e onde deve encaixar
E no meio deste infinito
é só desse modo se explica a simbiose
que poderá resultar deste momento em que
eu estou aqui a falar
E vós E vós estais aí ouvir
e entre nós
e as palavras
e os silêncios que se prescinde
significado e música uma espécie de
poesia sem palavras
E aí
e eu tenho eu para vos oferecer sim
o que tenho eu para vos oferecer
o ocorre de nada cheio de tudo um pouco
do paladar que sinto da vida na verdade
um pouco de artes é raciocínio a
sensibilidade perante o mundo que nos
rodeia
e o deslumbramento aquele que nos pasma
perante a vida
E aí
e quem aqui ainda se faz mal com a vida
e quem esse paz me essencial com quando
acabamos de nascer
com quem
[Música]
Olá eu sou uma paz mada
e eu ainda sou uma paz nada a
o e através das palavras que consiga
exprimir esses meus encantamentos
Eu costumo escrever sobre isso
e às vezes calão
o e fico no meio do silêncio e com o
tempo com o tempo do mundo e o infinito
e fico com a espada
[Música]
é surpreendente mente pasmada E no meio
do Silêncio por aí hoje prefiro falar
vos talvez fazer você sentir um pouco
daquilo que sinto quando me sinto pasmar
planta um abraço um simples e Mary o
abraço Esta palavra quase em desuso na
prática por via dos tempos em que
vivemos é capaz de nos fazer estremecer
um simples abraço e
nós fizemos tanto tanto de nos tocar de
nos sentir precisamos tanto de nos ter
no meio de nós precisamos tanto mas
também precisamos do azul do mar quando
toca o azul do céu ou do vento quando
brinde à Vida com as folhas das Árvores
É sério dos Poetas sabem as palavras mas
não sabem segurir
E cria universos que nos oferecem para
ser implantados eles dão à luz os
estados emocionais seres humanos que
nele se espelham
[Música]
e talvez voz e
o poetas usam as palavras para proteger
a vida para expressarem a alegria de
estar no mundo Começando por dentro de
todos a poesia pode conter todos os
abraços todo azul do céu Todo Azul do
Mar todas as folhas de todas as árvores
a poesia pode evocar todos os
sentimentos exteriorizar todas as
emoções colocar fora do corpo o coração
a poesia pov o infinito e
E são essas palavras sentidas Esses são
uma espécie de sopro
o que nos aliviam do peso das
circunstâncias e
o e numa sociedade
a cada vez mais visual
a cada vez mais a distância e distante
e os lembrar-vos importância das
palavras ditas olhos nos olhos
[Música]
sussurrados ao ouvido
Oi livre sauditas compulsar decoração do
batimento cardíaco transpiradas a
Oi tá bem as palavras podem mimar
abraçar tocar e ter no seu íntimo mil
desejos uma que ele que me trouxe aqui o
de vos desejar uma bela tarde um
belíssimo dia e uma vida cheia de gente
Bela lá dentro capaz de vos dar de
verdade sempre um abraço infinito e que
continuem a paz Março com cada amanhecer
porque ainda estamos vivos e as palavras
são só por de luz depois disso não
precisarei de vos dizer mais nada e voz
voz não precisaremos mais do meu vir os
na
o silêncio se tiraram todas as palavras
do mundo até da natureza
Oi Fran silêncio os seios do ar que se
respira numa planície Alentejana um
silêncio sem fim e tão cheio de tudo não
precisar antes são nem luar Ele
precisará bastará que se encoste ao
nosso peito e saberíamos que sabemos Mas
será que horas para nós para que haja
outra vez um sopro de luz que nos guia o
seguimento deste infinito e que saibamos
que vamos ficar em
a todos vai lá
e vamos ficar todos bem
bom obrigada
E aí